you're gonna see things that look and
feel familiar but they're not do not let
yourself get stucked in emotionally if
we're not back in 48 hours they need to
close the breach on earth-2
Mary is protecting your world and I will
lead to flash now
they could be stuck there forever
hey youtubers it's Charlie so maybe you
just died watching that teaser killer
frost is so amazing so let's do a quick
breakdown and they did post some more
images featuring other characters other
earth-2 versions of our characters
biggest thing first so what's going on
the team goes to earth to it's a
two-part episode part one is called
welcome to earth 2 as Harrison wells
says in the trailer everything looks
super Art Deco 20s industrial age it's
like everyone is dressed to go to a
Gatsby party with a few exceptions
killer Frost's and death storm clad and
leather rolling into the club and that's
where they are in this scene it'll make
sense when I say it's jitters it's like
the earth 2 version of jitters they're
gonna be seeing a lot of familiar places
that's why Jay Garrick tells them not to
get emotionally attached to anything
that they see you're gonna see a lot of
familiar things do not drink the
kool-aid and I know there's this WTF
moment of the trailer where it seems
like Barry runs into himself from
earth-2 because later we see him in
jitters dressed like he's going to a
Gatsby party with the bowtie on bowties
are cool cannot wait to hear some Doctor
Who jokes but then later we see him
running with the bowtie on with the
Lightning lighting up so either one of
two things is going on Barry does not
meet himself and he just dresses that
way when he learns that everyone else is
dressed that way so that he can blend in
or it really does meet his earth to self
and they swap clothes and he tries to
masquerade around as his earth to self
killer frost has that line where she's
like which one of yous from the wrong
universe she's probably talking to Cisco
and Barry but the whole idea of this
two-part episode is to find zooms lair
find where he's holding Jesse quick
rescue her and bring her back to earth
one that is why the second part of the
crossover is aptly titled escape from
earth - so next week welcome to earth -
week after that escape from earth - and
at the end of the month is the king
shark episode so you have a two-part
earth-2 storyline then king shark all
back to back it's gonna be amazing
so I've already done a big killer frost
video I've already done a death storm
video I'll put links for that in the
description obviously the character is a
little bit different than they are from
the comics I'm totally cool with the TV
show changing things it's still gonna be
so awesome and let's talk about some of
the other characters we run into earth -
iris earth to Joe West and earth to
Floyd Lawton Deadshot haven't seen him
in a while that was a big surprise when
they posted these pictures so
start with the big stuff first iris it
looks like on earth - she may have
become a police officer and her father
earth - Joe became a lounge singer or
performer of some sort maybe this is the
Flash's way of doing a musical episode
Jesse Martin is this amazing Broadway
performer he was actually performing I
don't know which show it was but he was
actually performing a Broadway show when
the flash people reached out to him
asked him to be Joe West on the show
because in real life Grant Gustin is a
huge fan of Gene Kelly and dancing and
dancing performing Jesse Martin there's
this rumor behind the scenes that he
teaches Grant Gustin tap moves whenever
they're in between takes so maybe we'll
see some dancing maybe we'll see some
singing
it looks like we'll definitely see Joe
West singing but you kind of get the
idea here different earth different
choices lead to different outcomes so
Joe West instead of becoming a detective
became the singer or whatever you know
whatever he's gonna end up being
whatever it is that has him performing
at jitters at earth - jitters I love the
fact that it looks like this really
classy bar just remember everything on
earth - style-wise looks like it belongs
in the great gatsby so if you've seen
that movie that's kind of what earth 2
looks like despite the fact Harrison
wells of earth 2 said that their level
of scientific development is way further
ahead
so think think of earth to people as
being a little bit smarter a little bit
further ahead but a little bit behind
style wise and just to talk about floyd
lawton no idea what he's doing in the
episode or if he's dead shot on that
earth obviously he's not dressed in his
gear so he might just be a regular guy I
can't wait to find out it's gonna be so
much fun there's gonna be other people
will see two other really familiar
things just look for different versions
of very familiar things that we've seen
before jitters Joe iris killer frost
death storm just the best examples of
that just a small slice of that remember
this is a two-part episode so it'd
almost be like this two-hour movie
here's my big question for you guys let
me know in the comments do you think
that zooms lair is in a very familiar
place like a twisted version of a place
that we know really well so train
station what does that remind you of
Daniel West with the Speed Force battery
that was powering the Train in the new
52 version of the flash he got in an
accident with that in the speed force
that was powering the Train infused him
with Speed Force abilities the Train
also merged with it like the wreckage of
the Train like the metal of the Train
became his soup like it fused with his
body so if you watch my flash episode 12
video I explain why I think wally west
might be a version of daniel west from
the comics you can see how meaningful it
is that zooms lair is inside the train
station there's just so much imagery
from the new 52 flash run so take that
for what you will will probably get a
good look at it during this next
two-part episode and if you want to
learn more about the origin story for
daniel west why I think he's wally west
just watch my flash episode 12 video
from a couple days ago but I almost
forgot Jay Garrick so there's this Jay
Garrick storyline where our flash goes
to earth to sow their flash has to help
our earth there's gonna be a big
metahuman attack so Jay is gonna have to
nut up and be the flash again but he
doesn't have a speed so I believe
Caitlin does something to take
velocity-6 to velocity 9 I think Caitlin
plus velocity 9 plus Jay Garrick equals
some really awesome Jay Garrick
storyline next week I don't know exactly
how it's gonna go down but it's gonna be
awesome so be sure to subscribe to get
that video I'll be doing the new rounds
of the reverse flash ring giveaway
whatever that starts - there will be
some Batman V Superman stuff this week
maybe Suicide Squad I'm hearing that
they're gonna sit out the Super Bowl so
I don't think there's gonna be a Suicide
Squad or Batman V Superman trailer on
Sunday it'll be mostly a Marvel Deadpool
stuff still a whole bunch of stuff going
on though well I guess wait for that to
post you can click here for my Deadpool
kills the Superbowl video yeah you can
click here for my legends of tomorrow
video from Thursday thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight